get acclimated and involved right out of
the gate Prince gets his first bucket
for Brooklyn and the steel fits inside
his path crosses over on Allen a step in
vine lavertus teal Harris right now is
one on two waiting for his teammates
Kyrie Irving deep three from downtown is
it bad that I started laughing as soon
as he shot the ball but you got the
right mindset right now to the outside
here's Kyrie Irving leaves it for Harris
a three
Joe Harris you look at the whole time
Kai Reed knows where he's going to be
able to throw that little past behind
and Joe Harris's expect to release
Irving the hesitation goes to the left
hand
Kyrie Irving the magic man means cheap
sticks with him
Irving the baselines right behind the
back Jared Allen very bravi tough pass
great catch and left hand way to work on
that left hand great catching great left
hand finish that's with a chance to tie
or take the lead
Irving for the lead curving the switch
he's got Koran
Irving
he's gonna cook you I mean watch curving
a3 you knew we missed it Prince Knight
the ball what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content